last time i'm sitting on the couch like
scrolling instagram and i get a
notification emily jackson is live with
rachel parcell i'm like oh man let me
see what my favorite girlies are up to
so they invited me up on the live i was
on the live with emily amy and rach
parcell and jackie join the live um and
it was really kind of the best night of
my life can't lie i feel so close to the
sister scala now it was just a joy and
they say like never go live with your
heroes they do say that but they're
lying yeah that was special that was
special so i'm just kind of like writing
that high ever since then it's hard to
like come on the show and do the show
like knowing that like last night we
were live with the sister scala and it's
like now we're just here with each other
yeah like it's just it's not the same
it's not like it's not doing it for me
if i'm being completely honest like when
we're talking live with sister
emily rage in the comments no i know it
was um
yeah so this is great
having so much fun here
love the show
there's nowhere else i'd rather be